[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
nine different underwater and Aquatic
monsters that will be seen in 2023 and a
few that have already been seen as of
now in April so let's get to it number
one the Dinosaur turtle seen in the
Mandalorian series The Dinosaur turtle
was a massive non-sentian reptile the
Beast was known to be vicious and
attacked both the mandalorians as well
as Chum down on a giant flying creature
called the Raptor it had an armored
height and the only Firepower capable of
piercing through it was an N1
Starfighter and his Torpedoes were able
to kill it the dinosaur tell walked on
all fours meaning it was quadrupedal and
had a long tail its skin was almost
impenetrable to Small Arms fire its
shell was likewise resistant to the
thermal grenade detonations it lived
underwater but could also walk on land
without any problems
number two the lake monster although
this Kaiju movie was released in
Thailand last Autumn it has yet to be
seen or viewed in other countries so I
will include this on this list as well
well the story goes as follows a young
little country girl finds an unusual egg
in a field and brings it to her hometown
then later a 9 meter tall monster
emerges from the lake spreading havoc in
order to reclaim her egg and later the
newly hatched child from that egg
personally I've seen the movie and the
lake monster is actually a folklore
creature that resides in a lake and is a
sentient reptilian animal the way it
appears on screen however gives off a
dark horror Vibe number three the
mythosaur also seen in the Mandalorian
these were enormous underwater creatures
as well as amphibious creatures
discovered on the Outer Rim world of
manalore it is thought that the
Mandalore mines were firmly their home
or one of their layers they were
allegedly tamed and written by the first
Mandalore Mandalore the great and other
ancient mandalorians as well but were
thought to have died out and went
extinct long before the Mandalorian
cataclysm yet at least one of them one
mythosaur survived and thrived in the
Living Waters during the age of the new
Republic and it was the same one
discovered by bohatan
number four the black demon this shark
will be spotted or seen in a few days
time in April of this year the black
demon according to accounts from
fishermen all around Baja California in
Mexico is a large black shark species
that inhabits the waters in and near the
dreaded Seas we see a monster shark the
size of a Megalodon possibly 60 feet or
18 meters or more on Avengers mission to
finish off the humans on the oil rig as
soon as they fall into the ocean in
various scenes as was seen in the
trailer the black demon resembles a
great white shark rather than a
Megalodon but its size is comparable
nonetheless as well as its ferocity and
Terror
number five another sharp the Megalodon
well this species of shark featured in
the movie The Meg and soon again in the
sequel called the mech-2 the trench
Bears its Origins deep beneath the
Mariana's Trench in beneath the
thermocline layer that separated an
underwater home from the outside ocean a
pair of Megalodon sharks escaped the
place in the first movie well the first
Megalodon sharp was discovered captured
and was around 45 feet or 13.7 meters
long but the second one was much larger
at around double the size 80 to 90 feet
or 24 to 27 meters long the second one
gave birth to a live young juvenile
Megalodon that will be the focus of the
next movie
number six Master verse Godzilla well
the Big G will be seen again this year
in live action in a series called
Godzilla and the Titans he as you all
know by now is a 400 feet tall all a 120
meters tall Titan that has his origins
in the hollow Earth and was a member of
a super species that has been in
existence since the Permian period
around 250 million years or probably
more than that the most of us G-Man is
an amphibious monster but spends most of
his time underwater swimming through the
oceans or taking rest in underwater
caverns and refuge here's as of now the
only Godzilla version to actually
possess gills which are organs that
allow a creature to breathe underwater
so yeah he is an aquatic creature
number 7 the titans of the most diverse
and yes if there is Godzilla then there
will be other giant monsters as well
otherwise as a guardian of the earth and
generally a good guy in the master verse
it would be boring just to watch him
walk around without any fights or Mayhem
since this will focus mainly on the
timeline between Godzilla 2014 and King
of the Masters in 2019 we will see
Monarch discovering dominance all around
the world including the Aquatic
Leviathan The titanus nakika and others
even Mark Yeager the calendar was killed
by Godzilla during this time frame as
seen in the novelization might make an
appearance
number eight Gamera in the greatly
awaited Gamera rebirth series a new 6
episode anime series set to premiere on
Netflix shortly the Monstrous Turtle
Kaiju will again be revived for the
screens the official teaser trailer had
already been published or released
revealing that Gamera will face 5 Kaiju
over the course of six episodes Gaius
Jaga and three others Gamera in his past
iterations have always been described as
an underwater bioweapon created by the
atlanteans and I see no reason that
there would be a change in his origin
stories for this new flick because you
know as a turtle he is obviously aquatic
of a sea creature
and number 9 Godzilla zero and once
again the last entry is none other than
the king of the Masters himself who will
be seen in a new incarnation in a yet
Untitled picture by none other than Toho
itself which will be released in
November this year
for fun fans have already given it the
name Godzilla zero and despite the lack
of a trailer we all know that Godzilla
is and will always be an aquatic Kaiju
with the exception of the godzillasaurus
origin myth which is still mutated to
live most of his existence underwater in
the end so yeah aquatic we don't know
how he would look like but since it's
Touhou it won't be a disappointing thing
unless they're wearing the old dancing
Godzilla suit again then kill me now but
I don't think it'll happen
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
take care Fam I'm beginning to feel like
a rap god rap God